donations to rebuild notre-dame
cathedral are flowing in from all around
the world this morning as crews in Paris
assess the damage from yesterday's fire
towering flames raced across the top of
the nearly nine hundred year old
Cathedral turning some of its
world-famous architecture well into ash
fire crews say about two-thirds of the
roof was destroyed but the two bell
towers somehow survived today francis
junior interior minister said some
weaknesses were found in the structure
of the cathedral but so far it's holding
up hundreds of firefighters worked for
more than 12 hours to put out the fire
one of them was seriously hurt but no
one died
you can hear the pain in many people's
voices as the cathedral spire collapsed
in the flame leaving on lookers in shock
many in tears people of all ages
gathered through the night told hands
pray and sing hymns French officials
believe the fire was an accident and it
may be linked to this renovation that
what they were doing notre Dom is one of
the most historically significant
structures in the world containing
priceless artifacts dating back
centuries
roxanna Severus in Paris where she has
seen some of the objects authorities
managed to save as they fought the blaze
in this iconic building Roxana good
morning good morning Notre Dame also
known as our ladies sits here at the
heart of Paris its beauty and history
drawing around 13 million visitors a
year this morning a city official showed
us some of the artifacts that were saved
from that fire such as candle holders
chairs and paintings he said it was a
miracle that these things were saved but
he says it's not yet clear how many
other relics were destroyed towering
over the City of Lights
Notre Dame has symbolized the soul of
Paris as the 14th century nearly two
hundred years after construction began
during the reign of King Louie the
seventh the Gothic cathedrals iconic
stone gargoyles pier over the city its
colorful stained glass windows and
soaring arches make it one of the most
recognizable Roman Catholic landmarks in
the world but it's much more than just a
majestic monument Notre Dame Cathedral
represents what's the most inspiration
about the human project and to see that
reduced to ashes my oh my
Notre Dame has housed several holy
relics including a crown of thorns
believed to have been worn by Jesus
Christ luckily it was rescued from the
roaring flames merci merci beaucoup the
Parisian shop the Cathedral has also
played an important role in US history
American and French troops celebrated
there after liberating Paris from the
Germans in World War two over time the
exquisite exterior has eroded but the
last major renovation here
was more than 150 years ago partly
inspired by Victor Hugo's depiction of
the cathedrals decay in the Hunchback of
Notre Dom a novel later adapted into
several films there's a risk to the
whole Cathedral it's falling down last
year we took a rare look behind the
scenes at the latest round of repairs
aimed at restoring the cathedrals
crumbling facade which was estimated at
185 million dollars you know the name
itself
Notre Dame our lady she's my mother
that's where I decided to become a
priest Reverend Michael Perry has
travelled from Brooklyn to nutri Dom
every summer for 27 years that community
is decimated my heart breaks to them
French president Emmanuel macron has
announced a fundraising campaign to
rebuild the Cathedral already two French
billionaires have pledged that together
they will donate more than 300 million
dollars as part of that effort
John Roxana Saberi in Paris for us thank
you Roxana
you